let's go to james from louisville
kentucky what's up brother james how are
you doing
hey good morning dr d thanks for taking
time to take my call man thank you so
much for calling what can i do for you
i'm i'm calling about our seven-year-old
daughter alexis
yeah tell me about alexa we've been told
by multiple doctors she's had separate
anxiety as well as anxiety in general
and we've tried a lot of different
things but really just need help to get
to the bottom of her anxiety and how we
can help her out
some active duty military and mom is a
stay-at-home mom
um and when i was or when alexis was one
i was deployed for about a year and
moved back in with her parents well i
was
fine okay and so when did you get when
did y'all
see the symptoms of her anxiety emerge
so basically ever since she was a baby
she was very always needed to be held
wanted somebody around
all the time and it just kind of
continued on from there
so basically her entire life so tell me
about the stress
in your wife's life um so
stressing my wife's life i mean she's a
stay-at-home mom
has both alexis our oldest and madeline
our youngest around all the time
and we're away from family most of the
time
being stationed halfway across the
country most times so
um very small support structure in
person
um a lot of time talking to family and
friends on the phone and things like
that but just that
interpersonal seeing somebody face to
face and having that adult interaction
back me up to when your wife finds out
she's pregnant with alexis you all are
excited this is your first daughter and
then you get the
deployment orders walk me back to those
that that season those few months there
yeah so um actually when we found out
she was pregnant we were
um actually pretty close to all of our
uh
support structure back on the east coast
and then um
about halfway through the pregnancy find
out they're
gonna transfer me to california
so completely across the country um as
soon as i get out there
find out we're deploying so then we
figure out okay well what are we gonna
do
um what's the best way to handle this
and that's when we made the decision um
it's
better for her to go back to go back
home and be close to
her parents my parents all of her
sisters for that support structure
gotcha and so then you're overseas were
you in
active combat uh no i was in uh kandahar
okay um so then you come back and your
daughter's how old too
yes he was um she turned two about a
month after i got home
so you get back to california did your
wife then turn on and fly back to
move halfway across the country back to
or all the way across the country to see
you guys again or do you move to new
jersey what's what's your what's your
re-entry like so i came back to uh
pennsylvania that's where
she was staying i was gone um we spent
about
30 days there where we
picked up the family and drove back
across country
to uh get back to our life in california
okay so paint me a picture of your
daughter's five
and you got a new little one in the
house what's a what's a
outburst what's an anxiety outburst that
you experienced with her when she was
five she was six she was seven
walk me through something um so
now a lot of her um things always needs
to be in control
if somebody else is trying to say oh we
need to do this
no i no i want to do it this way i want
to do it this way
um so that is our biggest thing right
now
is like she's very bossy with her little
sister
um you know when if we tell
madeline hey we need you to do this
alexis will turn around and echo the
thing to tell her to do it right right
so what's uh what's a
anxiety freakout look like just an
absolute barn burner um
she starts screaming no no no
i hate this um i can't do this we're not
doing it
no just completely shuts down
um how do you guys respond
so a lot of the time like we'll see it
coming so we'll
um take a step back and um
we have a couple different things that
we've done for
like [ __ ] calm down box um okay alexis
let's
take a break for a minute go go to
wherever you choose in the house
sit down relax we're gonna come back to
this in a few minutes
um but when it gets to the screaming and
i hate this
and everything um it usually turns into
okay go sit down in a room quietly for
a few minutes and gather your thoughts
um
and then we we re-engage after a few
minutes of
trying to get her to settle down and us
settling down too because
it's pretty stressful on everybody right
okay so here's a couple things i want to
talk through in general abroad and you
may have heard this stuff
um have you all seen different
psychologists
medical doctors counselors all that
y'all been through all down all those
roads
yes okay uh is she on medication or
anything right now
uh no no medication okay so um you may
have heard some of this some of this may
be new
um there's several things at play here
number one um they've gone all the way
back and done studies that show
this sort of disruption and disconnected
disconnection happens in utero
uh meaning that um babies who are not
yet born begin showing signs of
anxious depression um adhd though of
what i would call
disconnection they start showing that in
utero
due to maternal stress and so you know
your wife
um she's probably awesome um
and her having this close family system
in new jersey and then suddenly getting
packed up and moved across the country
while she's pregnant
then her husband gets shipped across the
country and we don't know
what's gonna happen and is it this or is
it that and then she packs up and moves
so that's just show that's just me
hearing as an outsider
in five minutes there's a lot of stress
going
on right there and sometimes babies are
used as
numbing devices in that in that type of
transition
or they are used um they are they are
can be pushed aside
in close proximity right so they can be
present but absent meaning
they can be sitting right there on the
couch but a mom is thumbing through her
phone
um a mom is talking to other people a
mom is on her computer
and the kid is right there in physical
proximity they're
but they're not connected right they're
communicating but not connecting is the
way i like to say that
and so what a kid will start to do in
really short order
is they sense that kids co-regulate
themselves till they're about 12 or 13
and i think it actually goes to about 25
or 30.
um they are only who they are
in relationship to the people around
them particularly their mom and their
dad
and when they sense any sort of gulf any
sort of disconnection
they backfill that with this is my fault
and i've got to do something to fix it
and that's where you see young children
begin to rewire towards adhd or to
anxiety or to ocd
you named you nailed it it's a control
mechanism right
i'm trying they are doing whatever they
can in their tiny little five
six seven year old power to re-bridge
that gulf
and that can be expressed in power that
can be telling their
you know their brother and sister what
to be doing they can tell you guys what
to do right
um and so
i when i when i'm talking to moms and
dads here what i always want to back up
and do a couple of things number one
let folks know that your daughter needs
to know that her feelings are okay
the way she expresses them is not right
and it is okay for her to feel scared
and it is okay for her to feel like she
is losing control of the situation and
the sooner she can learn to articulate
that without it becoming a hurricane
or just a blizzard diarrhea storm all
over the house
then you can get into controlling the
behavior part does that make sense
does so and kind of that that
makes sense too because at school and
everybody
they all say oh she's great she always
listens she doesn't be supposed to
so right that outlines that too so she
is safe in those contexts right and
not in the dad's an army man safe or not
in the mom's beating her up safe that's
not what i mean by safe but i mean
relationally tethered
she's got a teacher who always shows up
who is always there who always looks
from the eye she's got her same
knucklehead friends that are always
there
always engaged in whatever shenanigans
are going to be engaged in but
she can count on that and she's able to
put the control
um that control wand down right
and when she enters back into her home
space
that's when she enters back into that
gulf and she feels like i've got to keep
this sucker
held together right and so what i like
to
um remind parents of is this
kids crave with every fiber of their
being they crave
boundaries desperate for boundaries
and they will bang their head and fist
and furniture up against those
boundaries to make sure they hold
school often provides that for them
church sometimes provides that for them
dance class or baseball practice those
provide those boundaries
and they are whole and they are firm
and so when she's in your house she's
gonna be banging up against those
boundaries all day long right
and if she feels like that boundary is
wavering
if it's gonna fall over if she's got
somebody challenging hey your feelings
not real
um that boom it falls
the fence falls over and that's when you
get into those stone
freak outs right those i hate you i hate
everything because that's just a
like an emotional um volcano right and
when you're a young child you just can't
rein those in sometimes
so i want to be real careful about using
go away as a response to a child in an
anxious moment
anxiety is a disconnection disorder
it's a the way your brain copes with
being disconnected
even if you're disconnected in a crowded
room even if you're disconnected on the
same couch
so what are some things some
psychologists and counselors have told
you guys to try
uh so sometimes they say
i mean obviously she doesn't like
surprises so um
saying hey tomorrow we're going to do
this in a couple hours we're going to do
this
not surprising her with something new so
um
planning things out using visual
charts for like a bedtime routine
to say okay you know you need to brush
your teeth
setting those routines is one of the big
things that they have said
will help and then also
like that um the down box is something
that when she does get into
um one of those
big areas just having some things that
she can do to uh calm down before
re-engaging in the conversation so what
i wanna
i wanna recommend y'all do this i want
to recommend moving
way upstream and helping her develop
control in another way
and so i would love to have you and your
wife
and her i don't know how how young your
other child is how young madeline is but
i want you all to create a a set of
family values
that you co-create together and instead
of focusing so much on the behavior
you've got to get her amygdala to slow
down
and the way you do that the way a child
absorbs that
is through eye contact through touch
often
hugs um often touching kids faces
like a lot of i touch my son's face and
my daughter's face
every single day of their life twice a
day minimum
in the morning and at night um touching
their feet
and so instead of making this all a
cerebral exercise where you're focusing
a lot on the frontal lobe here's some
information here's some things that
you're doing
i want you to get to um and you probably
learned some of this in your military
training i want you to get to
more of the fight-or-flight response way
upstream
and so the way you let her know that she
does not have to be in control
is not through more information it's
through
touch it's through you being present
it's through your wife being present
so i want you i'm gonna give you guys a
30 day challenge
in your household i want you and your
wife to make a commitment
that there are no phones and no screens
in the room when the kids are in the
room
and that might be really hard it might
be really easy i don't know the the
rhythms of your home
but i want your kids to know when
they're in the room
that they are you are present you are
listening to them you are talking to
them you are engaged with them
and they can feel you number two i want
your daughters to see
you and your wife hug i want him to
hear you say positive things lovely
things reassuring things to your wife i
want you to show up for mom
and they are going to become
increasingly
less volatile by watching a
strong anchored in relationship in their
home
right and so if you and your wife are
having marriage issues i want to
strongly encourage you guys to go get
marriage counseling on your own
and create a tree of stability instead
of a hurricane in the middle of that
living room right
and then number three again touching
their face touching their feet
eye contact come up with a set of family
values
that she gets to be a part of and that
way when she does
lose it which is going to be fewer and
fewer times is my prediction
because she's proving she can do it at
school she's proven she can do it on her
friends so that tells me that she's not
out of control she doesn't have
you know operational defiant disorder
right she's not all over the place
this is a matter of her trying to regain
control and what she feels is an out of
control ecosystem
so when she does step out of step out of
control when that sucker goes off
right then you can refer back and say
hey you've chosen
to step outside of the values that we
all four created
and so as a part of that i it breaks my
heart because i want you to be at the
table with us i want you to be right
here
but you chose to step out ah i can't i i
hurts my heart
let's go do our time in the box and then
and then as soon as you're ready to step
back in let's step back in
and what we're trying to do is show her
that she's got control way upstream
and she can just whoo
let that control mechanism go
right let that control mechanism go
childhood anxiety is tough man because
you want the
little girl that you love so much to be
whole and well
and it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking heartbreaking
james i want you to know that i'm
thinking about you
control the chaos outside of your
daughter's heart and my guess is
outside of her her need to hold on to
things
control it bring the bring the
temperature of that room down
outside of her and give her some
structure upriver and let her be a part
of that
ah i'm looking forward to hearing back
call me back james i want to hear how
that goes